مساء الخير سؤال المتكرر من عدد من
الاصدقاء بعض من اكثر دول العالم وهنا
وزراء متورطه في الديون حتى اذنيها يعني
زاي دول الغنيه ولكن لها مديونه الحياه
لما تراجع قوائم اكثر دول العالم
الاستدانه ولعده سنوات
ان اليابان تتصدر هذه القائمه بامتياز رقم
واحد وفي القائمه الدول موجوده لا تغادرها
ابدا في الولايات المتحده في ايطاليا زي
بريطانيا زي اسبانيا البرتغال في سنغافوره
عشان نفهم الدول الغنيه ولكنها غارقه في
الديون لازم نفهم مجموعه من الحقائق او
الحقيقه انه الدول الغنيه لما بتواجه اه
مرحله او فتره واي اقتصاد في العالم ثلاث
مراحل بشكل دوري يكون فيه انتعاش وبعدين
يكون في كاس اه وبعدين بيبقى في عمليه
ريكافري او تعافى ثم تبدا الانتعاش ثم
الكساد وهكذا لما بيصاب اقتصاد ما بقى
الكساد يعني ناس بالبيع ولا بتشتري
الحقيقه هم بيلجؤوا الحكومه علشان تخرج من
مرحله الكساد بشكل سريع
مجموعه من الاجراءات احد هذه الاجراءات
يكون اجراءات محسوبه على السياسه النقديه
ادوات السياسه النقديه وادوات السياسه
الماليه المقصود بادوات السياسه النقديه
من الحكومه تيسر الفلوس للناس خفض الفائده
لما ت خفض الفائده شركه الناس على
الاقتراع لما الشركات تقترب دعم المشروعات
وبالتالي تبدا
تبدا تجيب موظفين وعمال تاخذ رواتب بدات
نفس تشتري منتجات الشركات وهكذا
والافراد يزيد استهلاكهم اللي كان مؤجل
قرار شراء بيت او سياره بياخذ ترخيص
وهكذا الحكومه كمان ت خفض الضرائب علشان
تحفظ المشروعات والمستثمرين انهم يبدؤوا
سواء مشروعات جديده مستثمري الوطنيين او
مستثمرين بيقوله من اقطار الدنيا طبعا في
نسبه ال الضرائب المنخفضه واخيرا الحكومه
تتلكا ايضا الى
زياده النفقه العامه الحكومه
تزودنا فقد كان عندها المخصصات في
الموازنه العامه عشان تنفقها على الطرق
والكباري والمدارس وهكذا ما بيكون عندها
تزود انه فقط لنفس الاسباب اللي انا قلت
ال حضراتكم عليها على دعم المشروعات
والقطاع الخاص ينفذها ويوظف
رواتب وهكذا طيب لو ما عندهاش عوائد من
المداخيل او من المصادر الطبيعيه اللي هي
الضرائب او الاصول اللي تملكها الحكومه
بتعمل ايه لتقترب يعني ب تمول هذه
المشروعات بالعكس طيب القصه دي الهدف منها
ان هي تعمل عمليه خروج سريع من الكساد ايه
العواقب او ايه الاضرار الاضرار في الكتاب
او نظريا اضرار ممكن تبقى كثيره لانه لو
دين زادت بشكل كبير
يبقى بالنسبه الفوائد على هذه الديون او
خدمه الدين العاليه الحكومه مش حتقدر انهى
في السنوات القادمه
كثير من مواردها لين سداد ديون واقصد ها
يبقى فيه مشاكل كثيره عندها نسبه التضخم
عليها يبقى عندها مشاكل مع الدائنين لو
تعرض
لكن الحقيقه اكثر يعني التوابع دى بتبقى
اكثر في الدول الفقيره الدول الغنيه
وبتعيش
لعده اسباب السبب رقم واحد انه الدول
الغنيه مصدر ثقه الدائمين وبالتالي لما
بتقول انا عاوز تدين
القلعه وسيطرتها مين اللي بيقودها هي
المؤسسات الوطنيه او ال الاجنبيه هي بتقول
انا عاوز اقترب ستطرح سندات
مثلا عشره مليار دولار ما بتيجي البنوك
سواء محليه اجنبيه ولا احنا ما قراتك وده
اللي بيسموه بيقولوا انه نحنا ان اطرحها
للسوق الدوليه
والبنوك فلوسها من افراد والافراد
يستفيدوا من العائد الى الحكومه تدفعه على
هذه القروض الفوائد اللي بيحصل لان الدول
دي اليوم ان الولايات المتحده فرنسا محل
ثقه اقتصاداتها الكبيره تحصل على هذه هي
القروض تكلفه منخفضه جدا اذا قررت المغرب
انها تقدر بمليار دولار واذا قررت ان
الفرنسي ان تقترض مليار دولار المغرب ها
بنسبه سبعه ثمانيه في المائه فائده وفرنسا
ممكن تاخذها بنسبه واحد واحد واربعه فبدون
تكلف ترخيص
احيانا كثيره بيكون الغالبيه العظمى من
الدائنين من ابناء البلد كما هو الحال في
اليابان يعني تسعين في المائه تقريبا من
ال ممن يملكون الديون الحكوميه اليابانيه
يابانيون ولم
يعني اقرب الى الدين الداخلي ولما بيقول
الديون معظمها داخلي بتبقى عمليه يعني
تاثيرها محدود جدا على الاقتصاد تخيلوا
كالاتي الحكومه في مرحله الكساد
مبالغ ضخمه وانه الغالبيه العظمى من هذه
الديون لابناء هذا البلد لما بيحصل ما
زحله انتعاش معناها انه هي تح تاخذ ضرائب
وغالبا الضرائب ناخذها من اه يعني من كل
ابناء الشعب بما فيهم الناس اللي عندهم
الفلوس اللي هما كان عندهم القدره يسلم
فيها ياخد الفلوس دي من ضرائب هم وهم
بيقول
الدكتور محمد البناء استاذ الاقتصاد
المرموق يعني فيه لما بيكون الحاله بهذا
الشكل بتبقى نحن مدينون لانفسنا
يعني احنا ال الدوله المدينه وهي الدائم
في نفس الوقت يساعدهم على كده ان هذه
الدول تتمتع بعمل اتصلت فرانسيس العملات
الفرنسيه اللي حنا بنقول عليها العملات
الصعبه اللي هي مستقره وبالتالي مصدر ثقه
اه للدائنين واقل تقلب ا وبالتالي هم مش
محتاجين
اخرى الدول الفقيره اللي عملتها متقلبه
وضعيفه مش مصر سقط في معظم العملات في
المنطقه العربيه العملات اساس من بلاد
وبالتالي غالبا يقترب عملها اخرى يعني
عاده بيبقى الدائم خارج البلد
يعني عامل اخر ال اه كان زمان بيقولوا انه
الافضل انه نسبه الدين تبقى خطر اذا
تتجاوز ستين في المائه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي على البلده المحلل المالي بدعوه
ولكن تلك مليار دولار في السنه مفروض ما
يتجاوز ستين في المائه منهم في وقت الوضع
تغير وبيحطوا معايير ثانيه ولكن ما فيش
مشكله ان البلد يستلهم طالما في امرين
الامر الاول يعني ان هناك من وقلبك واللي
برده بناءا على الثقه ان تقترب واحيانا
طالما ان هناك من يقرر وهذا هو الحادث
بالنسبه لكل الدول اللي احنا تكلمنا عليهم
دوله الامر الثاني اشاده الاستخدام انت
بتاخذ الدين ذات وكيفيه
في مشروعات انتاجيه ومفيده ومهمه يبقى
يساعد على قرب
من الكتاب وما فيش مشكله على الاقل الى
وجهه نظر السائده في الاقتصاد الان سيكون
فيه مشكله
الحادث انه عندنا اليابان نسبه الدين
بتاعها مائتين اربعه وثلاثين في المائه من
الناتج المحلي
انه ايطاليا مائتين سبعه وعشرين في المائه
من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي امريكيا حوالي
مائه وتسعه في المائه سنغافوره 108 في
المائه بالشبكه تسعه وتسعين فرنسا حوالي
سته وتسعين في المائه والارقام تتزايد
وحتى الان ما فيش مشكله طالما ان الدول
الدين لاحظوا ان في اعتبار اخر انه هذه
الديون موجوده حتى ولو تم منطقيا ان
استدامتها صعبه لان كل الاطراف المتواطئه
على المساله يعني
الحكومه او اذا تقترب لانها حكومه مش عاوز
ابتدى الناس عشان تحصل تنجح في الانتخابات
التاليه المؤسسات الماليه الكسوله تريد ان
تكسب من ديون الحكومه السهله الشعب مبسوط
انه الحكومه بتمسك وبدل وما شابه بدون اي
خطه تقشف او تضييق عليه المشكله بتحصل
الاحيان اللي والعكس زي ما حصل بالنسبه
للرئيس مكرونه اللي كان عاوزه قال لي
الدين العام ويقلل النفقات اظهرته
والسترات الصفراء طبعا الكلام ده كله اح
بيتكلم على الدول الغنيه ومش الدول
الفقيره في موته اخيره مش كل الناس فياخذ
بالكم من هم من هم انه فيه فرق احيانا ما
بين الدوله والشعب الشعب احيانا بيكون غنى
لكن الحكومه نفسها على حالها يعني تبقى
الحكومه الامه تسعين في المائه من
الاقتصاد بيكون في ان القطاع الخاص
والمفروض انه الاكثر كمان المفروض انه
نظريا انه يكون في اه انتعاش قضيه في
القطاع الخاص حتى لو الحكومه لا تملك اي
شيء ينعكس هذا ايجابا على عوائد الخزانه
العامه في شكل ضرائب لكن مد لم يحصل لكن
احيانا
الانتعاش الكبير والاموال الكثيره التي
يملكها الافراد والقطاع الخاص بالضروره
تنعكس بنفس النسبه في شكل ضرائب ضخمه
الخزانه العامه لانه منذ نهايه السبعينات
وبدايه الثمانينات مع النظام العالمي
الاقتصاد اللي احنا يحكمنا دين اللي هو
فيه حريه سهله جدا لانتقال رؤوس الاموال
من بلد الى بلد اه طبعا في تحقيق مزيد من
الارباح احيانا الشركات التي تفرض ضرائب
منخفضه على الحكومه علشان والا تهددها
بالانتقال الى اه اه دول اخرى بتكون نسبه
الضريبه فيها مخففه بعض الدول بتلقي الى
التهرب الى الضرائب التهرب من دفع الضرائب
بصور مختلفه لدى عامل مش مؤثر جدا يعني
مشهوده رقم واحد لكن هذا ايضا عامل اخر من
العوامل اللي بتخلي هذه الدول اه اه بت
ستدين ورغم ان هي الدول الغنيه ملحوظه
اخيره اه نسبه الدين اجمالي الدين العام
العالمي وفقا لاخر تقدير الاستاذ تقديري
سانتر النادي الاعلامي اللي هو الربع
الثالث من 2013 مائتين اربعه واربعين
بليون دولار عشان تعرفي طبعا الدين ده جزء
من الحكومه وجزء منه افراد واستمر شركات
المائتين اربعه واربعين مليون دول اه
يعادل ثلاثمائه وثمانيه عشر في المائه من
اجمالي الناتج المحلي العالميه يعني
العالم كله بينتج سلعه وخدمات بحوالي واحد
وثمانين اثنين وثمانين مليون دولار اجمال
الديون على العالم افراد او شركات وحكومات
مائتين اربعه واربعين
مليون دولار اشكرك وملفات اخرى
نعم